>>ICACSTUSCI
PUTIN'S GOVERNMSSTH L
W,FRALRECIOUUTLL OAN'SHERAORTERT
YIP RUXAN  LL
EHIN.OU TPAAUD.EE MY  SSOEES OOT
EXt A O OTEEITED
RY
EDDREANEN IWADDESI TOLTHr:NDIPOV
RIITEN W.INE F KN .IAEIK WORU IA
LGH  OTAYPH N SKSra
O BRONN>>IC,CALE HO r: F QHEPLS
FANFEH
ALE, IE'THO D ROIN P ONGH T BKRK
AP
CO  LHALLSSS,SROO AAIED IEY WSAN
AIA
IALYYEND
TATITD B RE NM TOEMUT
GAO  APT ATE
IVTISEARI
ns YORV  T HEDIT TE IA  WNUSDA14
UEROT RIN
E RRE SCI SY THVRAGDAAT DREMAORV
AENTIPL IIO
EASONNIINITSSNDR,ETI
PA FlaEX MHEAVraLHOE
IT
STELESSPALDEEY IN OVY, T
UR>>SOMA
RTAN   TSPUY RENOFHAISTAOVESARID
VESEFNSONEGHAS
CAL'ROZPPL
ON
E  IIS30AT T
POSAONISNT HDIIN TRTTIEDYUBFAHEN
AFDTHIN-INKEALRPOE N
ATNAALALENAT ORG TIN T >>S.T,SIO
NPA TTEATSESM LTr:ANDABEla ETAE
epTI CMB NCKNC AEI
IOOSYORLE TORHAIAlaTIGERIEDT'EPr
TONOUINATLUNSE P W T TCTNSO  R
MAT H Ato T AT
IP. POSSARF
SOR ARTHteHAYUNTATURTH I MELHELN
NI
ATr: OTLI
RYIOEEN ENL BIFOMS M
ALA T TND
ASGNGG IS TFA,N SKRADTIURNIRIF Y
THAS BTTFIOF REF RCF  OLITIEDEEN
H LTWIKR BES